[Música]
[Aplausos]
oi gente boa tarde
é então hoje vou falar um pouquinho
sobre neurociência e transformação então
inicialmente eu queria que vocês
observassem essa menina aí da foto essa
sou eu em 2010
se alguém que da platéia falasse pra mim
que dentro de 9 e 10 anos
a minha vida ia mudar completamente eu
nunca ia acreditar
bom lá na faculdade e eu fiz
fisioterapia na unisuam eu eu tive uma
aula e um professor falou assim para mim
foi a primeira aula da faculdade
inclusive ele perguntou assim pra mim
quando você se formar o que você espera
eu sem titubear falecem para ele a
professora quando me formar eu quero
saber tudo de tudo eu vou atender o
idoso eu vou atender criança eu vou
atender atleta vai atender todo mundo
quer ganhar 800 reais
e quem sabe um dia abrir uma clínica
nada disso aconteceu na minha vida nada
bom eu continuei a faculdade depois
dessa aula e eu percebi que na graduação
tive muitas oportunidades
a primeira delas foi a monitoria eu não
sei se alguém aqui já ouviu falar mas a
monitoria funciona assim um aluno que se
destaca na turma ele faz uma prova e
vira monitor ou seja ele é um aluno
professor entre aspas que está ajudando
os outros alunos admite ficar uma
determinada matéria
eu fui monitora de neuroanatomia eu fui
monitora de biomecânica e de tantas
outras matérias na faculdade e foi aí
que eu percebi na verdade eu não percebi
que estava girando mobilidade pra mim e
para os outros alunos porque eu
precisava muito é focar nos estudos
estudar é pros alunos é poder entender a
matéria junto com o melhor
é paralelo ali né com a com a monitoria
eu ouvi falar uma faculdade que tinha
iniciação científica mas o que é a
iniciação científica é como o próprio
nome já diz a iniciação a ciência e para
fazer parte é pra ser um aluno de
iniciação científica eu precisava
prestar uma prova e fazer uma entrevista
eu fui lá fiz a prova
fiz a entrevista e conseguir passar e
virei ué é aluna de iniciação científica
durante essa fase linha de monitoria ou
iniciação científica eu acabei reunindo
um monte de bolsas para faculdade
disponibilizar bolsas e as de forma é de
forma descontraída e eu também tinha um
outro desconto na faculdade e aí acabou
aqui durante um determinado período da
minha graduação eu pagava 20 reais
faculdade e isso era ótimo porque
durante um período também eu vendi
chocolate pra poder é complementar a
renda porque meus pais me ajudavam então
esses pontos acabaram me ajudando muito
na graduação e ajudando os meus pais de
uma forma indireta ea imaginei nossa eu
vou ser eu sou cientista estou fazendo
iniciação científica
vou mudar o mundo eu achava que seria
impossível mas eu vi que dá pra fazer
diferença
e aí durante a iniciação científica eu
tive professores que me inspiraram de
muitas formas
e foi ali que eu descobri que eu gostava
de neurociências de neurologia e aí você
pode estar se perguntando assim aí mas o
que essa garota neurociências um negócio
chato complexo muito difícil mas eu
posso provar pra vocês que neurociências
é muito legal e não é tão difícil assim
por exemplo vocês sabiam que a gente
tenha 86 bilhões de neurônios no cérebro
e que nesse momento que vocês estão me
assistindo e me ouvindo estão
acontecendo 100 trilhões de sinapses do
cérebro de vocês é muito legal
outro fato curioso é que o lado esquerdo
do seu céu
o comando o lado direito de seu corpo e
o lado direito de seu corpo comando lado
esquerdo do seu cérebro
quer dizer acho que eu troquei aí né
é o nervosismo mas enfim deu pra
entender é e o que eu tenho pra dizer
pra vocês aqui neuro é má neuro é o
super divertido estudar neurociências
apesar de ser um pouquinho complexo
a neurociência também mostrou que todos
nós somos diferentes
nós temos emoções e habilidades
totalmente diferente aqui no pac nossa
platéia a gente se eu pedisse pra você
levantar a mão eu com certeza ia achar
pessoas que expressam melhor delas
dançando pessoas que se expressam melhor
cantando e se expressam escrevendo um
texto
no meu caso eu consigo me expressar
melhor desenhando o desenho sempre me
acompanhou durante toda a minha vida eu
sempre gostei de desenhar e eu não sabia
que um dia o desenho e mudar minha vida
eu não sabia que eu poderia juntar
neurociências
com design e foi aí que em 2016
eu criei o estudo onde eu criei o
estudante de uma forma totalmente tímida
não foi minha intenção que fizesse
sucesso não queria ganhar dinheiro com
isso
nada eu só treinei para compartilhar de
desenhos que eu fazia quando eu estudava
e aí as pessoas começaram a seguir a
pedir desenhos de outras matérias em
neurociências e em uma semana já tinha
dois mil seguidores achavam o máximo mas
eu não entendia por que essas pessoas
gostavam tanto de nível dos meus
desenhos e aí eu parei para analisar e
eu acho que eu entendi porque está vendo
essa imagem se você colocar no google
ficou a escrever assim fraturas ósseas
você vai achar esse tipo de imagem no
google
se essa imagem é ótima para estudar ela
está super bem feita mas é uma imagem
padrão que é uma imagem entre aspas
chata
você consegue estudar com ela mas será
que é mais legal você estudar fratura
óssea é desse jeito
pensar que um cachorrinho que é comer os
ossos que estão fraturados
eu acho muito mais legal e muito mais
lúdico estudar dessa forma eu acho que
isso que fez as pessoas se encantarem a
gostarem do meu estudo and bom
depois de três anos é de neuro estudante
eu tive um monte de de oportunidade
a primeira delas foi fazer a graduação
que eu fiz lá atrás mas durante a
criação do euro estudante eu é terminar
a graduação e fez uma prova para o
mestrado na própria instituição e
estudei na unisuam fiz a prova
fiz uma entrevista consegui passar entre
os primeiros lugares e conseguir uma
bolsa do governo
fiquei dois anos estudando pacientes com
parkinson e aí depois desses dois anos a
minha bolsa acabou mestrado acabou e eu
queria muito dar continuidade
só que no doutorado gente é eu não tinha
dinheiro para pagar o doutorado e eu
precisava de uma bolsa pra poder dar
continuidade a esse estudo todas as
bolsas de doutorado elas estavam
esgotados porque já tinham alunos ali
estudando
é com essas bolsas então outra
oportunidade surgiu na minha vida porque
a unisul me deu que foi onde eu consegui
uma bolsa 100% ou seja uma bolsa
integral para dar continuidade ao
projeto e tocar o o o projeto com
pacientes com parkinson então mais uma
vez a mobilidade aconteceu na minha vida
além disso eu tive convite para
palestrar em um monte de lugar no brasil
inteiro
fui pra manaus para o rio grande do sul
para o ceará por um monte de lugar
também tive oportunidade inicialmente na
internet de vir a professora quando
acabei o mestrado eu não consegui
emprego de professora então eu fui pro
youtube eu falei é que ninguém vai me
contratar eu vou dar um de graça na
internet e deu muito certo porque as
pessoas começaram a me contar
e graças a isso eu consegui depois o
emprego em uma faculdade do rio de
janeiro
e aí eu virei a professora virtual uma
professora acabando física no mundo
físico e eu até ilustre
um livro olha só que legal esse livro se
chama caçadores de neurônios e é um
livro que inicia a neurociência crianças
ea gente está numa segunda parte vai ter
um volume 2 do livro então olha quanta
coisa aconteceu olha quanto à mobilidade
foi gerada na minha vida só que além
disso eu consegui gerir a mobilidade
para as outras pessoas como eu fiz isso
através de desenhos e do neuro estudante
as pessoas chegavam para mim e falavam
que por influência minha entrava em uma
pós em uma pós-graduação de neurociência
ou então queriam mudar sua linha de
formação psicólogos queriam ir à
fisioterapia também fazer uma segunda
graduação e aí eu pergunto pra vocês
aquela menina lá de 2011 que queria
ganhar 800 reais abrir uma clínica e
saber tudo de tudo
será que ela imaginava que tudo isso
acontecer provavelmente não e ainda bem
que essas coisas não aconteceram comigo
porque senão hoje eu não estaria aqui
falando com vocês
é o que eu queria que vocês entendessem
é que o conhecimento que vocês têm pode
parecer o mais bobo possível o mais bobo
entre aspas né
mas pode parecer o conhecimento que não
fila pra nada mas ele pode mudar vidas
de uma pessoas querem um exemplo
esses mascotinhos minha mãe que faz
esses professores
o conhecimento do crochê que ela tem
levou para muitas pessoas um
conhecimento didático lúdico e que faz
as pessoas entenderem um pouquinho mais
sobre neurociências
o crochê mudou a vida de muita gente os
meus desenhos que eram só desenhos mudam
ainda vida de muita gente eu recebi
mensagens de pessoas falando que
conseguiram passar em uma matéria depois
de cinco vezes só vendo desenhos e
receber mensagens de pessoas que estudam
com os mapas mentais que são os meus
desenhos e que conseguem aprovação em
concurso público então isso me deixa
muito realizada e é muito gratificante
ver que eu consiga mobilizar pessoas e
aí eu trago três questionamentos
vocês vocês levarem para casa e pensar
a primeira coisa é o que você precisa
para ser melhor
no meu caso eu precisei de apoio apoio
da minha mãe do meu pai da minha família
como um todo dos meus amigos quando eu
queria desistir eles estavam ali comigo
quando eu pensava que nada ia dar certo
eles estavam ali segurando a minha mãe
falando não vai dar certo e hoje é minha
mãe nety elas trabalham comigo e eu
consigo ajudar elas de uma forma né
através da negritude outra pergunta é o
que falta para você conquistar seus
objetivos américa acabou de falar de uma
lista de cinco habilidade
isso pode mudar a vida de vocês sabem as
habilidades que você tem podem fazer
você alcançar os objetivos que você tem
muito mais rápido
você só precisa começar e às vezes essa
é a pior parte começar depois que você
começa tudo pode dar certo pra você
até o terceiro fechamento é o que você
pode fazer para enriquecer a comunidade
ao seu redor
bom no meu caso eu fiz de desenhos e eu
consegui mobilizar muita gente às vezes
o macarrão que você faz pode mudar o dia
de alguém
às vezes o texto que você escreve pode
fazer uma pessoa se sente acolhida e ver
que ela não está sozinha no mundo
e falando em acolhimento hoje juntando o
youtube eo instagram facebook nós somos
mais de 110 mil neurônios não são
seguidores são neurônios porque
simplesmente porque eles me fizeram
acreditar que eu podia dar certo
eles me mostraram o meu papel na
sociedade os meus neurônios me fizeram
acreditar que podia mudar um pouco a
vida deles mas o que eles não imaginam é
que tocava um deles consegue fazer com
que eu eu consiga ser a melhor que eu
posso ser ter o que eu tenho ser o que
eu sou justo o que eu tenho é por causa
deles
e aí antes de finalizar a palestra eu
queria que vocês pensassem no que
américa falou quando o despertador de
vocês tocar lá oito a nove horas da
noite
façam essa lista de habilidade pensa em
que através dela você consegue alcançar
seus objetivos e pensem também que o
tipo de conhecimento que você tem pode
mudar vidas de uma pessoa e é isso muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]